we helped from Montreal support the
development of Mass Effect 2 in Masek 3
and when that team that was driving the
first three games was kind of ready for
a change we took over they passed the
baton and we took it out with mass
Miguel romera so for me it was we're
being held in something that is very
precious by where is the thing that
we're going to use to determine what by
our mantra stands for is it a real
Bioware studio
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to part two of game sports look
at the story of Mass Effect Andromeda in
part one we looked at the impact of the
original trilogy and the floor or
surrounding Mass Effect threes
ending above a part two we're setting
our sights on the future after a
five-year break Bioware is charting a
new course for Mass Effect moving on
from the Milky Way and travelling
thousands of light-years away to the
Andromeda galaxy just days before its
launch Bioware attended PAX East in
Boston and for this episode we talk to
them about returning to the series their
vision for a new journey and the
challenges they faced helming the new
Mass Effect
[Music]
Andromeda is a game about venturing into
the unknown and exploring the unfamiliar
to find a new beginning themes that hit
home for the people making the game its
development team is a mixture of series
veterans and newcomers that joined by
aware as fans both bring something
different to Andromeda for veterans
andromeda is an opportunity to move
beyond Mass Effect's past to realize
unfulfilled ambitions and to make good
on ideas that they weren't quite able to
achieve with the original trilogy myself
and a lot of the mass spec team actually
moved on to work home on Bioware's new
IP at the time in there wasn't for sure
that we were going to do another Mass
Effect after a while even though I'm
working on this new IP is very exciting
you do have that nagging sigh you know
we never really got to do this you know
look at the Mako is just like we tried
to mass spec to to improve it we didn't
quite get it there and then we just said
no we're gonna give up we didn't have to
release another Mass Effect game right
we did it because we think that people
would love it and that we wanted to so
being able to kind of be free of that at
the very beginning from the ground up
and build this thing and conceptualize
and id8 on where and when and how that
was liberating for sure we weren't tied
into any previous sequels we didn't have
anything that we had to do we just we
were able to start fresh the jardin de
french has actually helped move forward
and say no Mass Effect is about looking
for an instant balance right bitterness
guy like Mike Walters Mike Hamill myself
at several people and then the new guy
is completely new which also brings
their own perspective saying we're hang
on I played the entire trilogy so I work
on three again so they played actually
the entire trilogy as players and they
say well the thing I remember is D'Amico
it was clumsy it was all that but me and
I have found memories of the making when
suddenly for people like us mostly well
okay we thought it was functional maybe
we should think about it yeah while bio
was old God ensures Andromeda feels like
Mass Effect it's the new blood that is
attempting to redefine the series
identity for these fans turned
developers Andromeda represents a blank
canvas an opportunity to take what they
loved about the series and build a new
future upon it so when I initially got
the call it was you know hey would you
be interested in being a designer on
Mass Effect and of course I thought they
were joking partially because it was me
but also partially because the franchise
did you say it was like it was ended it
was this nice hall thing I'm surprised
that they were they were gonna do
another one will be soon this in this
timeframe so when I when I interviewed I
talked to them a lot about the narrative
premise of the game you know what was
the set of what what we're going to do
each bold leap forward was achieved by
those willing to do anything to attain
it
we are all of us leaving behind families
homes the very birthplace of our species
and since I realized what what we are
now doing as as the setups like okay ii
this is definitely a way to let us have
something that feels like mass effect is
mass effect has lots of carryover but
doesn't require us to handle the 50
billion choices you may have made over
the trilogy that can be new but also
carry over the old like okay I can see
that working I'll do that
when we were offered the opportunity to
come work with my work on a mass effect
I say we because my husband is um
believe level designer so this is both
of us coming here of you know dream jobs
there is just not like yes we're gone
we're gonna do this oh my god what have
we done like cause this is you know it's
it's really incredible to be part of it
well that's dumb you don't see back home
[Music]
often it was very overwhelming and
intimidating but at the same time with
the talent we have it's no letting the
team also kind of take the reins and go
no there was of course correcting
involves but it's overall they let us
not only become part of the team but
help you know recreate you know what
we're doing right now I think I speak
for most people when I say that I feel
like an impostor all the time like oh my
god what if they find out that I'm
actually not as good as everybody else
here but you keep working with a team
it's all about the teamwork that journey
for me has been surreal as I said I've
volume to get into it since I was a kid
so getting a chance to actually squeak
in the door and work in QA was humbling
and then having working really hard to
get each of the additional opportunities
that popped up and then learning on the
job what even like my transition on the
mass effect it was a new journey for me
and I think it kind of resonates in
terms of the game itself it's all about
exploration and discovery almost every
single role that I take on is about
exploration and discovering and
trying something new when I first came
to Bioware I actually worked on show
tour I actually wanted to make the move
so I was working on SWTOR and I just
loved the Mass Effect franchise so much
that I wanted to to be on it and so I
actually applied from inside the company
I applied to Mac Walters and said please
I want to be a writer on me3 many hadn't
even worked on a Bioware game but they
were fans of the franchise so they had
only ever seen Mass Effect as a player
and they'd come in and and that's how
they sort of envisioned the world and so
they were able to bring like a whole new
kind of passion but a whole new
perspective to the to the world building
and and to how we wanted to build this
game out it was great because you know
like I said we wanted to look forward we
want to sort of keep an eye on the
future but at the same time I had these
these people you know that our ardent
fans and they would very much let me
know you know it's like it's like I feel
like maybe we're drifting too far away
from what Mass Effect should be and we'd
have a discussion about it and I think
that really helped sort of you know help
us find that sort of that fine line
between something very fresh and very
new but also very clearly mass spect and
when the level designer who previously
built the Normandy for the trilogy
shifted projects like Jess do you want
to do The Tempest and like yes I think
so
you know try to live up to what the
Normandy is you know for fans myself so
being given that opportunity was just
absolutely incredible to be involved in
all that and then partially along the
way started also leading what we call
this beast team which is pretty much
where we redesigned the galaxy map so we
took you know at the core of what the
galaxy map was in terms of you know
these are experienced but then what we
wanted to make it this beautiful
immersive player experience that
reinforced the narrative of writer as a
pathfinder
[Music]
it's been most interesting to see the
the sort of new take on this exploration
content that that we have never had to
build before and how we can craft quests
that are fulfilling and interesting with
interesting characters and people in
populate those worlds welcome to my team
I look forward to working with you
likewise in terms of the team it's been
a really good balance between people who
worked on the last ones and people who
who are bringing sort of new new energy
to the to the franchise Bioware is
hoping that by bringing these two
perspectives together under one roof
Mass Effect Andromeda can break new
ground while also staying true to the
spirit of the series and for me the
spirit of Mass Effect's has always been
its characters while saving the galaxy
from the Reapers right is what drives
you forward
it's the bonds you form with your
compatriots that makes that struggle
worthwhile Mass Effect's characters are
what turned that passion for the series
into an obsession they have the ability
to push past virtual barriers to move
beyond the screen and ingrain themselves
on the lives of fans whether that
through cosplay tattoos or naming
children after them but Bioware believes
that if massive
is to live on it can only do so through
reinvention and while it's able to lean
on series foundations such as planet
exploration role-playing systems and
kinetic combat for game play creating
new characters that resonate with the
fanbase is undoubtedly its greatest
challenge it's no wonder then that
returning to the series has sparked
trepidation and excitement in equal
measure the legacy and cultural impact
of Mass Effect looms over Andromeda and
no one is more aware of what's at stake
than its developers sometimes it does
dawn on me it's a big responsibility and
then I try really hard not to think
about it sometimes I drink and
eventually eventually you can get past
it and then completely forget coffee
liqueur like pastries I don't know when
you play Mass Effect 3 you've had three
games with garrus and you're like yeah I
went through so many things with garrus
garrus is my buddy but packing my Mass
Effect one guess was like a random
Tyrian right so so we understood the
hardships of being able to have to build
those characters up from the ground
again because they're all new characters
right how do we create a protagonist
that feels unique and different from
Shepard deep breaths you're gonna want
to take it easy I've been taking it easy
for 600 years and how do we create a
universe that feels like it's Mass
Effect but at the same time explores
different themes and allows us to try
new things and that's where you know
going to Andromeda I think really sort
of set the stage for that
the problem is again you come after
three games and everybody will have that
level of expectation because those three
games are a single experience and this
is a very important point people
remember a single experience not
necessarily three different games so
suddenly the level of the experience
you're going to provide has to be in a
way at that level that took three games
to make yes you have the weight of the
legacy and as you say I had also a
Federation ship or so a more emotional
relationship that it's not necessarily
on the development side I don't want to
be the guy who screwed master dick
obviously that's guy yeah sure I don't
want that but at the same time you need
to put that away Fraley quickly the
important was to place the pillars and
the plane between action and RPG the
importance of the character relationship
the role of space and the notion of
space opera the place of humanity all
that that will never change in any story
you tell Mass Effect there's no reason
to do that that's Mass Effect but again
it was obviously there was way way more
story to tell so you want to evolve
revolutions be careful right the kids
this it needs to be an evolution at the
same time as much as I still love you
know the first trilogy if you go back
especially to the first one it's quite
clunky so you need to make sure that
even though you're staying true to that
formula and it's a game that plays good
today
again we're not dealing in the same way
where we know it's a trilogy but we know
that we're planning the seeds for
something that we want to keep building
upon in the future so it needs to be a
formula that as we're refreshing it we
believe will stand the test of time and
is something that we can keep the other
Parliament I guess the major challenge
in creating these new characters fresh
is that I can't
I couldn't hear them yet so that when I
was writing Shepherd I could hear
Jennifer Hale mark Muir in my head as
I'm writing I knew who they were I knew
what they sounded like but you know Liam
and and and Gil and sube and callo now I
know but when we started I didn't and so
that that's a that's a challenge for
sure oh hey Pathfinder the Pathfinders
there let me say hi fine but don't
embarrass me Ryder this is Syd my sister
said Ryder
let me guess little sister are you
calling little look you know gotta go
wait
Ryder I just wanted to know if taking it
on from the previous mass spec team and
trying to learn on the job is definitely
tricky but at least our development
schedule while sometimes hectic has
allowed us the the room to make mistakes
and fail and then learn in failure and I
think we've embraced that a lot as a
studio which is quite nice it's
essentially learning the soul that is
Mass Effect and trying to make sure that
the game hits that note first and then
grows on it in new and interesting ways
we have a wonderful you know IP and more
and it would have been silly for us to
be like no we're rewriting everything as
we move you know to Andromeda's know
there's a there's a core foundation for
reason we're gonna take it build upon it
and it really drove us to make a lot of
the decisions in what we were doing
when Bioware launched the first Mass
Effect it did throw with the message
that it was the beginning of a trilogy
the move showed confidence in its
ambition and a dedication to its vision
the future for Andromeda however is less
definitive it's been pitched as a game
that stands as a self-contained
experience neither connected to the
series past nor outwardly motioning to a
future from the outside the reluctance
to commit to the series again it feels
like Bioware's way of saying that
although it sees a future and Mass
Effect
it may first have to overcome some
growing pains in many ways Andromeda is
trying to be the game mass effect was in
2007 Bioware Montreal is returning to
the original vision for the franchise
emphasizing exploration character
interactions and making the player a
stranger in a strange world once again
whether or not Mass Effect has found its
new beginning remains to be seen but
Bioware Montreal is confident that its
five-year struggle has been worth it
while the studio may be being coy about
the future of Mass Effect Beyond
Andromeda beneath the surface that same
ambition demos there's a lot of stories
to tell so what I hope is didn't we
actually keep telling stories and that
we also actually keep saying a true
science fiction franchise in the sense
that we're grounded with the world
around us we keep telling stories where
people can relate I will see more of
these characters and I going to do more
these characters to continue with these
people I want people to be hungry for
more whether it's more of writer or more
the the cruise squad if you come away
with this and you're like look more do
Who I do see more these characters and
then they'll be very happy so we've
spent a lot of energy and a lot of
effort literally just rebuilding the
universe so that we could we could
portrayed here plus bringing up forward
all these new things and now that we
finally got it to that stage it's like
okay now we can really play so we've
introduced crafting we've introduced
exploration vehicles again how deep can
we take all those elements and really
improve upon them so that you know your
next mass effects are are even more
immersive thing with game development is
that for so long it's it's about faith
because for so long you don't see the
end now they have time to sit back and
play the game and you can see this
mother on this to use it we built that I
never wanted to have a studio with a by
where name on the door I wanted to have
a Bioware's to give you and I feel that
with the release of that's if I can rev
it up we now have a buy our studio
you
huh